go ahead
good morning everyone
to be here today on the national
territory of the le congan speaking
people the esquimalt in songhi's first
nation and i'm joined virtually today by
minister mike farnworth
and we are going to be talking about the
challenges drivers are facing in british
columbia over the past number of weeks
and uh
some of the other inflationary pressures
that are affecting people's lives here
in british columbia
today if we go to fill up at the pumps
sometimes it feels like it's a bit of a
hold up uh prices are at unprecedented
levels
and those prices at the pump are a
direct result of vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine the challenges of
disruptions in international
markets and disruptions in commodity
prices are unavoidable not just here in
british columbia and in canada but
indeed around the world
but british columbians still need to
move around we have a robust
transportation network public transit in
our major urban centers but large parts
of british columbia depend on single
occupancy vehicles to get around as do
businesses who depend on using fleets or
vehicles to conduct their trades
throughout bc so with these increases
that we've seen
i asked minister farnworth minister
robinson the finance minister to look at
what options we had to provide relief to
british columbians
we want to make sure that we do what we
can to make people's lives a little bit
better that's been our focus since we
formed government whether it was
removing medical services premiums
forever whether it was eliminating tolls
for those who traveled in parts of
british columbia
whether it was ensuring that we fixed
what was referred to so graphically as a
dumpster fire at icbc the work at icbc
and the work of drivers across british
columbia have allowed us to provide two
previous rebates to drivers their money
going back to them
and also of course because of the robust
financial shape that the corporation is
now in we've been able to see a draft
drastic decline in the cost of a policy
but despite our best efforts to find
ways within the system to reduce costs
for british columbians we've gone back
to icbc once again because of again the
strong financial position they find
themselves in as we come to the end of
the current fiscal year and we've been
advised by the board and the executive
that we'll be able to provide
a one-time relief payment of 110 dollars
to personal drivers and up to 165
dollars for commercial transportation
these small contributions will be large
for many people across british columbia
and we're very grateful for the hard
work at icbc from the staff
and from those policyholders who have
reduced prangs and we've also seen of
course increase dollars through
investments and minister farnworth can
talk about uh the robust position of the
corporation at this time but we're
confident that these one-time
contributions of 110 to individuals and
165 to businesses are timely to help
ease some of the pressure on pocketbooks
when it comes to
gas prices this is again directly a
result of international war in europe
that has disrupted supply chains and
disrupted commodity prices i've looked
at other jurisdictions across the
country the only other provinces that
have public auto insurance
opportunities like this
saskatchewan manitoba saskatchewan has
taken
advantage of that and provided a similar
rebate to their drivers others have
chosen to address taxation and i've
talked about this
at some length but i think the public
needs to know that the amount of money
that they pay in taxes at the pump is on
the pump when you pull up you know every
time you fill up what portion is going
to translink if you live in the lower
mainland what portion is going to bc
transit if you live outside of
the lower mainland and in areas where
public transit is provided and you also
know that the the amount that we pay for
carbon taxes here in british columbia go
right back to people and to businesses
to drive down emissions by ensuring that
we can do retrofit programs and other
initiatives to make life more affordable
and reduce our impact on the environment
we were reluctant and in fact would not
amend the taxation because it would just
be filled by an increase in prices at
the pump and we saw that in alberta
where the government promised a 13 cent
tax reduction on a monday and on a
wednesday the price went up 14 cents we
believe this is the best way to get
money into people's pockets and i'll
pass it over to minister farnworth to
provide some of the details
thank you premier and good morning
everyone i'd like to begin by
acknowledging that i'm joining you from
merit on the and the lands of the uh
kaplan people
it's been two years since the kobit 19
pandemic disrupted our lives
during that time british columbians have
proven time and again how resilient they
are
we've experienced the impacts of global
supply chain issues and how how here in
bc we are affected by world events
the russian invasion of ukraine has
resulted in an unprecedented increase in
the price of gas and other day-to-day
goods
today we're here to announce relief
since may of 2021 icbc's new enhanced
care model of insurance has lowered
premiums while ensuring better care
the majority of customers renewing their
full personal auto insurance under
enhanced care have saved on average 490
dollars per year
this follows two cobit 19 rebates issued
by icbc last year that provided drivers
with an average of 300 combined
i'm pleased that we are able to issue a
relief rebate this spring
drivers with personal policies will
receive a rebate of 110
while commercial customers who generally
incur higher expenses will receive a
rebate of 165 dollars
it's a total of more than 395 million
dollars going directly back to the
people in british columbia
people will begin with to receive their
rebates starting in may
this is one more way that this
government is making life more
affordable for people
thanks very much
uh thank you as a reminder to media on
the phone line please press star one to
enter the queue you're limited to one
question and one follow-up first
question today is from rob shaw check
news
oh hi premier uh i know that translink
yesterday announced it's raising fares
uh 2.3 percent and i think there's an
argument some people have made of why
not use
some of this money for public transit
here in victoria or in vancouver lower
the prices there rather than give it to
motorists directly
make a more economical or better overall
solution through public transit did you
think about that or why wasn't that part
of this
well we did look at the taxes at the
pump which is uh certainly
there are people in the community who
feel that this would be a more
appropriate way to act but we've had
advice from
ubc economists and others who have
advised us that a reduction in taxes at
the pump would only be replaced by an
increase in the commodity price
similarly we believe that translink and
bc transit are operating in the public
interest they need to manage their fleet
they need to manage their fare box
to complement the work that are the the
resources that they can get through uh
gas taxes and any direct uh
contributions from orders of government
uh that's how it's been operating we
believe that uh this is the best way
forward to ensure that we're addressing
challenges in areas where there is no
access to public transit which is a big
big chunk of real estate from
outside of the lower mainland throughout
most of uh northern interior british
columbia
we had uh certainly loud heard loudly
and clearly that there are many people
who do not have the opportunity to avail
themselves of a world-class transit
system as we have
in our metropolitan areas so this we
felt was the best way to ensure that we
could protect those
drivers and also those who would uh have
inflationary pressures brought to bear
as a result of uh vladimir putin's war
in europe
rob do you have a follow-up
sure thanks uh i know your government
has said in the past many times that the
bc liberals used icbc like a piggy bank
taking profits out of it to spend on
things when it was in a strong financial
position
rather than letting the corporation use
the money internally to prepare for the
ups and downs of an insurance company
are you not doing just the same thing
here using icbc as a piggy bank to
address a a problem and taking money
away from it no well and i don't believe
we are we brought in legislation to
prevent future governments from dipping
into reserves at icbc to pad their
budgets what we're doing here and what
minister farnworth has explained for the
two previous covet
benefits we're giving money back to the
policyholders the people who finance
icbc this is a rebate based on the
robust position that the corporation is
in and that full marks uh to the
executive and the management team as
well as the board uh for transforming
what was a dumpster fire
aptly called
into a corporation that is in a position
to provide relief to the people who
funded the policyholders and perhaps
minister farnworth can can add to that
but this is this is apples and oranges
comparisons this is about giving the
money back to the people who put it in
the pot not taking out of the pot to
meet political uh needs within
government please go ahead minister
oh thank you and just just to follow up
on that so
icbc's significantly stronger uh
financial position than was predicted at
the beginning of the uh of the fiscal
year uh this year uh and as a result
it's not only able to meet its capital
requirements uh but also allows us in
the uh in the case of uh of of this
particular year to be able as the
premier said to rebate uh some of that
money back to the policyholders uh the
ones who are uh you know financing the
the company through through their
insurance their insurance policies
uh it's not going back to general
revenue it is going back uh to the to
the individual policyholders
next question is from cole schizler
black press
are you there cole
okay sorry hi can you hear me now yeah
yeah thanks for taking my question um so
110
for the average driver depending on
where you live that's
about a tank and a half a gas maybe less
um
how far is this hundred and ten dollars
really going to go to make life more
affordable for british columbia
well i think it's a significant
contribution at a very difficult time
for drivers as they look at the price at
the pump to know that there's relief on
the way i think is is going to be
positive news
i appreciate that government can't
buffet or protect consumers from runaway
prices
other than using the tools that are at
our disposal to reduce costs and in this
instance we're able to provide a
an amount of money back to policyholders
to drivers to help them along the way i
believe that it'll be welcomed
it is again by comparison to the uh the
the move in alberta which won't take
effect until april first it was based on
the price of the commodity and it was
going to be a direct tax reduction which
would work out to about five bucks a
week
so 110 dollars uh in a one-time fund or
five bucks a week as uh the alberta
situation uh is going to manifest itself
i think we'll be welcomed certainly uh
on border in border communities where
there's an opportunity to uh
to shop across the line uh we want to of
course keep people in british columbia
but uh consumers uh are driven by uh
price and the price point they'll make
those choices those personal choices and
uh and we'll leave them to do that
call do you have a follow-up
yeah um
sorry i i lost my question of it there
um if prices skyrocket further if we go
back to the you know over 220 mark at
the pump does the government have
further measures that you can take and
can you shed light on what further
measures might be at the government's
disposal well cole uh we're making an
announcement today we have capacity to
make other announcements in the future
but we're monitoring inflationary
pressures not just at the pump but
across
the economy and uh we're always ready to
step in if the need arises but today's
announcement stands on its own uh it
will assist businesses it will assist
drivers and we have other tools at our
disposal that we're looking at for other
interventions as
the spring unfolds and we get into the
summer we do not know what the
consequences of vladimir putin's
aggression in ukraine a war in ukraine
will have on the global economy the
global marketplace so all governments
not just british columbia and i and i
think this is a a caution for people who
are tuning in right now and hearing me
uh speak that we are not out of the
woods yet we are in for a series of
a time of instability here in in british
columbia and in canada and indeed around
the world and so we want to ensure that
we're able to respond uh the minister of
finance uh looked at this very carefully
through our processes we didn't act
swiftly as some will argue i'm sure i
can i can almost read the liberal press
release now but we acted prudently we
made sure that we waited until near the
end of the fiscal year so that icbc
could have a clear picture of what their
financial situation was that's a
responsible thing to do
i pride
our government on our ability to be
prudent be focused but also at the
center of everything we do have people
in mind so as the summer
progresses as the spring progresses into
summer if there are further inflationary
pressures we'll be working to try and
find ways to reduce costs for people
next question is from yvonne raymond ctv
vancouver island
hi i'm just wondering how you came up
with a hundred and ten dollars for
personal vehicles and 165
for commercial what's uh what's the um i
guess significance behind the exact
number
i'll pass that to minister farnworth to
respond uh it's a direct result of the
financial situation at icbc and he can
shed some light on that go ahead
minister
yeah thank you uh thank you for the
question uh it's exactly looking at the
uh the financial situation of icbc in
terms of what was projected at the the
beginning of the year uh finding the
balance between what icbc required in
terms of its capital uh requirements and
what uh potentially would be available
uh to uh to provide in the form of a
relief rebate to policyholders that's
how we came up with the uh the uh the
number uh and it's about uh
395 400 million dollars that would be
available and then recognizing that
commercial vehicles uh
are on the road more have more x more uh
expenses uh and so
the 110 and 165 dollars was achieved uh
on that basis uh as a way of ensuring
that everybody is treated equitably but
also recognizing from the commercial
vehicle perspective that they do have
some higher higher operating costs
follow-up yvonne
no thank you
thank you next question is from von
palmer vancouver son
good day premier good day minister um
if icbc can afford to give this kind of
money back to policyholders
doesn't that suggest that icbc was
overcharging
and should have been offering these
rebates
this month in any event
well i'll again i'll let mike answer the
substance of that bond but
the available
resource to do this as a result largely
of investments that icbc makes as you
know to
ensure that they have uh appropriate
funds to manage any eventuality going
forward and the instability
caused in the marketplace has led to
an increase in value for commodities
that icbc may invest in but but mike can
give you more detail on that but it's uh
it wasn't about too many policy dollars
in the pot it was about uh having a a
positive year-end as a result of
investments that the corporation makes
on behalf of policyholders go ahead
minister
yeah no thank you i'm just following up
on that uh what we've seen since the
reduction of enhanced care was the
reduction in rates
on average of about 20 percent uh the
rates being frozen in place
working through the utilities commission
so for three years of stability rate
stability um that has allowed with the
uh as the premier stated the investment
returns that icbc has received to not
only deal with the financial position
that it was in uh to significantly move
to rebuilding the the capital reserves
for the uh the minimum capital test
that's required in the planets in place
around that and recognizing that because
of the uh the good financial management
there has been uh this ability to
provide uh a one-time uh
rebate based on the performance of the
icbc over the uh over the past year
von do you have a follow-up
yes please uh premiere uh you and bruce
ralston have both referred to a pending
report from the bc utilities commission
with its recommendations on how
to proceed
to manage or otherwise deal with
gasoline prices um and several times
referred to that it's it's coming soon
um what what can people when first of
all when can we expect to see that
report and
what can people expect
that it will lead to uh well vaughn i'm
not aware of uh the timing of the report
uh nor am i uh
aware of the content but i can say
broadly to drivers one of the
initiatives that we brought forward as
you know well was to bring forward
legislation to ensure that the
commission had the ability to look into
uh unusual increases in in the price at
the pump uh to ensure that there was an
explanation as to why the prices were
going up that allows uh customers uh
british columbians to have confidence
that there's no gouging going on you've
been covering this issue for a long long
time and you know that whenever there's
a spike
in prices there's an immediate uh
expectation that there's gouging going
on uh
the uh the anti-tax crowd says it's all
about taxes the taxes stayed the same
the price of the commodity goes up and
so allowing the utilities commission
that those who have expertise in the
field to review these increases and to
determine why the price went up how it
was being
declined how it will decline over time i
think is useful for the traveling public
and more importantly it's it's useful
for all british columbians whether they
uh
drive a a car or not to know that we're
not being gouged because of uh
challenges uh in other markets so i i
think that the the review will be useful
for government to understand what's
happening in the marketplace not from
a partisan perspective but from an
independent perspective which is what
the uh
the people at the commission can provide
for not just government for british
columbia
keith baldrick global news
oh hi was that me yes please
uh yes so uh
given the robust financial health of uh
icbc
uh it begs the question why wasn't the
rebate even bigger it wasn't just
investment income in icbc that has a a
better bottom line also claims are
dropping dramatically uh was the
expectation perhaps a little out there
that this rebate would have been higher
than 110 rick mcanlis former civil
servant who has intervener status at the
utilities commission his analysis
suggested he could afford at least 125
dollars this year
thank you for the question uh and i know
rick uh and he i i know that he is among
uh a handful of experts on this uh this
issue and uh i i certainly value his his
input uh but i have to say and and you
will know this uh keith that uh finance
ministers certainly for the past five
years have looked withdread at the
bottom line at icbc because it swings uh
so much in short periods of time and we
wanted to wait till the right near the
end of the fiscal year so we could have
certainty that the corporation did have
a robust bottom line and i have been in
this job now for five years and at this
time of the year i have seen more often
than not
the situation at icbc deteriorate over a
matter of days to a point where it's had
a material impact on our budget so
we wanted to make sure we were following
this and tracking it to the last
possible moment to give relief to
drivers but also to ensure that we were
not putting the corporation back into
the dumpster and mike can uh
talk about the uh reduction in accidents
and and what that means for the the
vitality of the corporation
yeah no we have seen a reduction in an
accident certainly through the uh the
period of kobit uh but we are coming out
of covid and we are seeing more and more
people on the road uh people getting out
to you know to
travel again in a way that they haven't
been able to do for the last few years
and so it's been critical that we try
and maintain that balance between
recognizing the strong financial
position that icbc has found itself in
at the year end with a recognition that
while claims have gone down during the
cobit period the reality is is we are
moving out of that uh and we we may well
see uh uh you know a potential increase
so it's a it's that balance between
ensuring uh this recognizing the strong
financial position
what icbc requires and um
the uh the the the surplus um or the the
unexpected to the the windfall if you
like uh that we can return to
policyholders in the form of a uh
relief rebate
keith you have a follow-up
yeah given again the the dramatic
turnaround in icbc finances and in the
fiscal plan itself the three-year fiscal
plan projects more modest surpluses in
the next couple years but
is it realistic for policyholders now to
expect rebates
each and every year
that's a good question and we have been
fortunate as minister farmworth has said
uh to have uh surpluses that were
sufficient to provide
funds back to the policyholders and that
was welcome news
and this i'm sure will be welcome news
as well
but uh we want to make sure that we're
taking these steps as they come rather
than looking too far down the road we
want to protect the hard work of drivers
and the
the team at icbc to get it back into a
position where we can make decisions
like this and taking advantage too soon
of that positive situation could well
imperil any more success going forward
we want to make sure rates stay low
and and the way to do that is to allow
the corporation to make these decisions
in consultation with the board and the
government and uh and that's what we've
been doing we'll keep on that track uh
always mindful that uh
again from our own personal experience
much less the experience of drivers over
the past decade uh price the cost of car
insurance was unsustainable for many
individuals and families we've been able
to turn that around because of hard work
by the corporation and by the team that
we sent in to find a way forward we want
to make sure we don't lose track of that
our last question today comes from mira
bain cbc
okay uh premier i know you mentioned
that you'll be monitoring gas prices in
the situation um uh that's happening in
ukraine but i'm wondering do you have
any sort of a hard date when you'll be
reviewing um
gas prices again you know this is a
one-time um
only uh rebate right now but could we
see another rebate in the future well we
do have as i said to in response to
another question there are other
mechanisms that we're looking at we did
look at but we have we have a
challenging period ahead of us as i said
the instability and the aggression of
vladimir putin is is going to be
affecting us for some period of time not
just at the pumps but at the
at the checkout at the grocery store and
a host of other areas and we want to
make sure uh that we're monitoring that
and uh ensuring that we have the
resources to respond uh when required
i have been engaging with my colleagues
the premiers across the country
on this issue we came uh we we were
driven by consensus the council of the
federation we weren't able to reach
consensus on how we would approach the
federal government uh to see what steps
they could take
but i do know i'm meeting with uh the
prime minister next week and
affordability inflation the consequences
that we'll have on a range of of issues
that are before our government and
before the people of bc will be a very
high priority
mayor do you have a follow-up
yes um and so this is a question just on
another front for the premiere um we're
just wondering whether
um ndp leader jagmeet singh sought
advice from you regarding the confidence
and the supply agreement um you know did
he talk to you about it at all and what
advice did you give him if any well we
did we did talk about it uh early on uh
shortly after the election and and
before the uh the agreement was
announced earlier this week
i'm pleased to say that
the work that we did andrew weaver and i
to create a
casa agreement here in british columbia
to provide stable government through our
minority period
has been duplicated in other
jurisdictions uconn is using a similar
model for their minority parliament
right now
when there were minority governments in
new brunswick and newfoundland i spoke
to not just the premiers but the
opposition leaders about how we were
able to find a way to cooperate and i
did have that conversation with the
prime minister as well as with judgment
singh i believe that what british
columbians and canadians want is for
elected representatives to cooperate and
collaborate to to get outcomes for them
only the most fierce of partisans and
you've seen this in the response to the
agreement that was reached by mr sang
and mr trudeau only the fiercest of
partisans would want to continue
fighting an election that was concluded
last fall what canadians want is for
their elected representatives wherever
they come from whatever their political
stripe roll up your sleeves and work for
us get things done for us and i believe
the confidence and supply agreement that
we had here in british columbia as well
as those that have followed will set the
template for how minority governments
work now and into the future and i would
hope
that the success of these approaches
would allow majority governments to be
more flexible in their engagements with
opposition parties and i would also hope
that opposition parties would see the
opportunity to be partners in the
delivery of programs rather than just
adversaries obviously we need in our
system to have an adversarial
relationship in the legislature or the
house of commons so that we can get
better outcomes but i think you can also
get better outcomes from cooperating
rather than just punching each other in
the face
that's all the time we have this morning
thank you for joining us thanks
you